bonjour gilbert pago et ben journée à 30
car oui j'ai vu bonjour à toutes les
auditrices et tous les audits
merci de martinique pour griller merci
d'être présent dans ce studio en direct
ce matin vous avez été enseignant
formateur d'enseignants
vous êtes désormais à la retraite vous
êtes historien et on vous a invité parce
que vous allez donc animé une conférence
jeudi prochain jeudi 21 mars à 18 heures
au sixième étage de la mairie de fort de
france sur le thème naissance et
premiers pas de foyal et ce dans le
cadre de l'année des 350 ans de fort de
france puisque 2019 marque
cette commémoration cet anniversaire il
y aura une série donc de manifestations
de conférences qui seront organisées par
l'association notre histoire caraïbes en
partenariat avec la ville de fort de
france nous aurons bien évidemment
l'occasion d'y revenir dans deux
prochains rendez vous sur notre antenne
met donc à propos de cette conférence de
jeudi soir naissance et premiers pas de
foyal gilbert pago l envie de vous poser
cette première question qui avait t-il
là dans cette zone de l'île avant
l'arrivée des navigateurs colons
français qui en feront fort royal il y
avait un immense marécage tout ce qui
est aujourd'hui le centre ville et les
terres sainville le fort de france
c'est un immense marécage une immense
mangroves et il a fallu d'abord dans un
premier temps pour voir donc les libérer
cette ville les amérindiens les
amérindiens s'y était aussi easy était
il s'occupait quand même senti qu'ils
occupaient vous savez que les
amérindiens c'était une population très
clairsemé c'était des tribus elle était
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs du côté de la
plaine de 10 lots près de la rivière
monsieur que tout à fait mais on a
retrouvé dans les fouilles vont à fait à
fort de france on a retrouvé des traces
des amérindiens
voilà et donc il y a trois cent
cinquante ans dans cette zone et créer
une ville mais qui n'est pas pour ainsi
dire on va dire la capitale de la
martinique ne l'est pas parce qu'on
avait déjà crié saint pierre depuis 1635
ont créé pour royal en 1666 c'est-à-dire
21 ans après et c'est saint pierre qui
était déjà la capitale économique
étaient déjà là
or et qui était aussi le centre
administratif alors fort royal qui est
devenu longtemps après fort de france
était une place forte militaire en une
alors qu'à celles non au départ c'était
différent
un petit fortin on avait misé auront
rocher c'est là où se trouve aujourd'hui
le fort saint louis
c'était ça et pourquoi on avait mis ce
fortin là parce qu'à côté il y avait une
anse extrêmement importante qui
s'appelait le qu'ils ont appelé le
carénage
c'est d'ailleurs le nom du quartier je
voudrais maintenant le carénage et que
c'est un port où on pouvait mettre les
bateaux et d'encrés c'était donc donc
quand on décide de créer ce qu'on
appelle la villeneuve du cul de sac
royal parce que c'était pas encore fort
de frost et fort royal
lorsqu'on décide de créer sa et bien
c'est à la fois un fort un port est en
fait une ville voilà alors mais
davantage un port militaire qu'un port
commercial a au départ cependant surtout
militaire miniterrain nationale oui
l'entrepôt est d'ailleurs la savane
c'était d'abord une sorte de place
d'armes où enfin bon voilà 4 à 10 ans
mais c'était cette instance est elle
allée medica s'entraînait alors vous
l'avez dit c'est un marécage bon il
faisait pas bon vivre
oui parce que l'humour est salubre sont
les esclaves qui ont participé à ça je
vais raconter cela oui comment il ya eu
beaucoup d'esclaves qui ont qui sont
morts et puis qui se sont révoltés qui
ont été fusillées par blayac et c'est
toute cette histoire aussi derrière ces
milliers d'esclaves qui ont fait fort de
france crif et oui alors j'en appelais
la villeneuve d'où coule de sa croisière
et ben oui c'est ce que j'allais vous
demandez pas ce que bon on a parlé des
colons évidemment des militaires etc
donc il y avait quand même beaucoup de
d'esclaves ont faim d'africains déportés
ou d'afro descendant comme on dit on à
mener d'ailleurs il ya un emplacement
qui s'appelle la pointe des dans
la périphérie du centre-ville
là pas loin de vous avez été directeur
pas loin de le s p e comme on dit
maintenant l'école normale la kiki qui
forment les enseignants la pointe des
il ya un rapport avec justement
oui parce que c'était là qu'on débarque
un certain nombre
le déporter en fin d'après- d'esclaves
qui arrivait en est parce qu on est
mettez la en mondial je trouve pas le
terme lorsqu'il avait 38 ans carole sont
cités n'ont rien d'autres mots plus
simples mais je ne le mot ne me vient
pas en les médecins la baule et euros
vitaliser quoi va les vendre sur le
marché de saint-pierre mis d'accord
maintenant il ya un phare un à la pointe
des phare marin qui qui voilà qui
est là pour éclairer les navigateurs
dites moi à fort de france est ce qu'on
trouve encore des traces des vestiges de
ce qu'il y ait encore des traces encore
visibles de ses premiers temps un jour
comme s'il y avait au moins le fort
saint louis qui est important et puis il
ya les tracés des premiers rue
d'ailleurs je vais en parler dans le
meeting pour montrer comment on avait
créé cette ruelle donc la fameuse grande
rue qui est l'actuelle rue victor hugo
d'accord ou bien la rousselle denis qui
est en fait là où shell cher
actuellement mais ouais mais c'est vrai
que fort de france ne peut pas comparer
à d'autres villes dans la caraïbe où il
ya beaucoup de traces d'aidé vraiment
des premiers temps de la colonne que
l'on a tout détruit et où on a eu un
comportement qui était que quand il
fallait refaire on détruisait et c'est
une erreur manifeste bon mais alors pour
terminer gilbert pago on parle beaucoup
de la terre bon on a évoqué que c'est un
port évidemment et puis il ya la baie la
baie de fort-de-france ou autrement
appelée baie des flamands
ça a été aussi le théâtre lors des
premiers temps de cette cité le théâtre
d'opérations notamment militaire de
guerre il faut savoir et que je dirais
de la conférence et que fort de france
du moins fort royal c'était la capitale
deux des 18 colonie française des îles
d'amérique
c'est à dire toutes les îles de plus les
îles et la terre ferme c'est à dire la
louisiane mais aussi l'île de la tortue
sainte croix saint christophe saint
barthélemy saint martin la guadeloupe
marie galante
les sept la dominique la martinique
sainte lucie saint vincent les
grenadines grenade de tobago bas tous
étaient des colonies sait pas faire tous
étaient des colonies françaises et la
capitale deux des îles du vent mal
c'était froid royal donc voila et donc
il y avait effectivement beaucoup de
militaires et d'activité administration
administrative excusez moi donc voila et
bien on a évoqué avec vous gilbert pago
historiens la naissance et les premiers
pas de foyal mais je veux insister sur
ce que vous avez dû le début lorsque
nous allons fêter c'est toute l'année
commémorative en est à dire tous les
aspects de faux roi yan non seulement
fourni un militaire non seulement
fauriel religieux non seulement faux
royal artistique non seulement faux
royal architectural non seulement faux
royal féministe non seulement fauriel
écologistes en fait et y compris
quelques grands événements comme par
exemple la venue de béhanzin ou bien les
événements de décembre 59 il ya toute
une série on la priora chez-nous
expositions concerts musicaux etc des
râles et donc une année commémorative
dans laquelle on va parler toute l'année
c'est toute l'année de tous les
évènements de forêt y est d'accord donc
vous aurez certainement l'occasion de
revenir en parlait ici ou là sur
martinique la première nous donnerons la
parole aussi à des membres de
l'association notre histoire caraïbes
donc qui a concocté avec vous tout ce
programme tout au long de l'année mais
le coup d'envoi sera donné donc ce jeudi
soir je le rappelle à 18h au sixième
étage de la mairie de fort-de-france
conférence de l'historien gilbert pago
naissance des premiers pas de foyal et
on annonce qu'il y aura justement vous
parliez d'autres expositions il y aura
une exposition photographique un siècle
de photos de fort de france début avril
à partir du 4 avril
voilà merci gilbert pago d'être venu
nous parler de ce rendez vous ce premier
rendez vous d'une série importante
concernant donc foyal devenu
fort-de-france bonne journée à toutes et
à tous
[Musique]